ce site est unique en france
trois hectares de vignes en plein coeur
de la commune de valence et dans l'indre
il s'agit d'un clone exceptionnel par sa
qualité sa superficie le clos de valence
est qui abrite les vignes du prince de
talleyrand s'élèverait depuis 10 ans
grâce au dévouement et au savoir-faire
de hubert saint sont bien connus des
amateurs de bacchus
il faut savoir que dans tout le siècle
dernier il ya une vigne si c'était la
vigne presse on sait qu'ils devaient de
bordeaux mais peut-être que les autres
personnages du château bel 20 est donc
une opportunité s'est trouvé en 1990
pour récupérer cette terre c'est ce que
nous avons fait et donc nous avons créé
renouveler la vigne brasse de talleyrand
délaissé depuis quelques années ses
vignes votre arbre de mieux que de la
surpopulation chine balancer vers
saint-lô et mettre en place depuis 90 et
cette année cela revêt une connotation
exceptionnelle des anglais
les moeurs cent quatre-vingt cinq marins
parmi les personnalités possède un vent
de 100 pieds anthony de vie bousculée
vendanges se font en année un très bon
d'avoir parce qu'il est valence et que
j'aime valence et que je fais des
spectacles depuis 20 ans ici et que
j'adore valence est et séville regarder
avec le château derrière et tout c'est
quelque chose de merveilleux
en rouge du prix nos deux gammes et est
du coup en blanc sauvignon et chardonnay
en rien que du très bon tennis de
l'exceptionnel soutien en tout cas une
grande fête et tous les invités du huis
clos qui jusqu à tarte et fois
dégonflera renée lixir qui vient de
traverser plus de dossiers